if i could play any marvel video what
should i pick what should i pick
god i was nervous i was excited uh but
[Laughter]
look at you which one won guys guys this
is the best interview of my life hi i'm
chris evans and this is my puppy
interview
where are these puppies
are they just gonna like come running in
here oh my god see i i have two of my
experts i have to chill because like i'm
expecting like a waterfall of puppies
[Music]
hi guys hi hi hi bobby hi
hi
hi
oh my god you guys are so sweet
hey had to happen hi pal
look at that face
hi
oh
my god
who cares
uh if i can play any marvel video what
should i pick what should i pick maybe
uh loki seems to have the most fun come
here guys come here
come here come over here come here hi hi
hi buster
yeah i did of course i did i loved toy
story when i was younger hi buster i
love toy story buddy oh man
this is a problem hi pal hi guys which
one what this is impossible hi belle
look at that face
hi
hi buster hi sweet man oh thank you
belle
[Music]
who
cares
maybe maybe the first one just because
it was the original hi bubby hi pal
[Music]
i was nervous i was intimidated i was
excited uh but
[Laughter]
look at you guys
guys
good luck come get it
come get it
oh man
this is terrible oh bubby
hi pal hey belle
hi busta brown oh my god
he's so sweet
uh i guess rex rex would be a good movie
right don't you think that'd be a good
one right
[Music]
i guess it depends on the movie villains
are fun they give you a little bit more
chance to play hi
hi man hi buster brown
hi
uh what's the one question i wish i got
asked god i don't know i can't think of
anything i mean what do you think buster
what do you think guy hi
hi
hi hi guys
hi hi
[Music]
when i was younger
i was younger i really wanted to be an
animator
this is the best interview of my life
hi guys hi guys hype out look at that
face
look at that face hi
[Music]
god that's a good sign maybe return of
the mac
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
to be 48 hours another avenger that's a
tough call because they're all such good
friends of mine scarlett's my girl
renner would be trouble [ __ ] would be
a lot of fun
hemsworth would make me feel bad about
myself i'm not sure they'd all have some
some uh
they it's it's an impossible question to
answer you guys scratch pal come here
let me get it i got you
[Music]
voice acting is it's daunting because
you really only have one string to play
on um and and it takes a minute to
realize how how colorful you can be
buster come here pal you guys are so
tough you're all flexing you're showing
off
you can't do that
about to go home with all these props
[Music]
well perfect squad we were both so young
um and that was back you know when you
just you know it's almost like summer
camp you're just so excited to be doing
what you love to do and it's just you
know you feel like a little adult going
out and having drinks and getting
dinners like you were grown up my nanny
diaries i mean she was really on her way
so
i don't know by then it kind of felt
like it was exciting hi buster come here
look at that mug you look a little
nervous huh it's okay pal
look at this guy hi buster
hi pal
look at that face and yeah look at you
you little troublemaker you little
troublemaker i don't know what is the
question
i mean by then she was like you know my
my sister we were so tight at that point
then it really felt kind of like we were
in our adulthood and really working on
something
really meaningful
look at this mug that was unbelievable
but now we're gonna bring in some older
dogs
[Music]
my dog dodger i i rescued him and he was
though a puppy technically he was
probably two years old at the time i
always thought when i adopted a dog or
rescued a dog it would be a little puppy
and dodger was a full-grown dog and it
wasn't the story i had in my mind but it
ended up being the best decision of my
life so i just think a lot of adult dogs
and
older dogs get overlooked and that's a
shame so let's give them some love too
hey hi hi it's okay come on let's let's
build some trust hi pal
it's cool
all right
you sweet guys who knows what their
story is i mean some of them oh guys god
it just makes you want to spend time and
earn their trust no better feeling than
earning a dog's trust is that
[Music]
yeah every morning it's play hi buster
hi pal oh look you see it's so sweet i
mean they just have such a such a
connection with whoever they've been
around for a while and it makes an older
dog's love so special you got to earn it
no disrespect to the puppies but
you know these guys have probably seen
some things and as a result they're a
little wary it's why it takes time i
really respect that
you're so sweet pal thanks for trusting
me bubba
[Music]
have
i don't know
[Music]
probably downey you know he's seen a lot
i've been through a lot and he's so
talented he'd be a fool to not listen hi
guy
hey guy you are so sweet
thanks bud thanks for trusting me
[Music]
let's cast adam driver see what he does
and who would i catch to play scott god
that's a good question i don't know i
think only scott can play scott little
shout out to uh pacific pups rescue for
hooking us up with these dogs today
they're all so sweet and they all need
homes so go to a shelter to find your
dog a lot of loving friends waiting for
you
excuse you
what a good man
good job bubba
you